welcome to washington i'm brett baer
breaking tonight the southern border
crisis at the texas border is about to
get worse because of a southern border
crisis at the mexican border with
guatemala that is the entry point for
thousands of migrants hoping to make
their way into the u.s correspondent
griff jenkins is in top of chula mexico
tonight good evening griff
good evening brett mexican officials
here say they've never seen anything
like this and that it dwarfs what we saw
in 2019 when we covered the caravans who
came through here now a staggering
number of migrants are struggling to get
out
it's difficult like a prison don't have
a rock they with nothing
you know you don't have a house to live
it
nothing nothing officials here say as
many as 10 000 haitians are stuck in
tapachula applying for refugee status
and work permits fighting their time
waiting to head north to the u.s a lot
of people asian living in mexico in
tapachula but
it's not the destination the destination
of the older people asian is in united
states it's overwhelming mexican
officials who say that so far this year
they've received over 77 000 migrants
which is already more than all of 2019.
the head of mexico's refugee commission
says by the end of september that number
will be close to 90 thousand nearly 71
percent of those migrants pass through
tapachula and some have a message for
president biden i want to say something
to president about it it will help us
because
everybody here
want to have a better life in the future
want to have a better
life tomorrow want to work will you go
back to haiti no no no no never never
however not all are from haiti many
still are from the northern triangle of
honduras guatemala and el salvador and
some from as far as ghana i did not pass
what would die
so it has become very difficult for us
and we have children they are sick and
then we need to go to the hospital it's
part of a pipeline of migrants running
from south america through this southern
mexican town and eventually the u.s
border i want to go to the united states
with my family the reason all the people
here in mexico want to do that
to have a better life
and brett mexican officials here in
charge of refugees in the state of
chiapas say they are preparing for an
onslaught of as many as 15 000 confirmed
migrants in south america mini haitian
many in colombia on their way here so
much so that officials tomorrow morning
are opening up a soccer stadium to deal
with the overwhelming numbers brett
griff jenkins in southern mexico tonight
griff thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else